hey it's Justine and some of you may
have seen that I launched my own line of
pink USB cables which I am so hyped
about but we also launched a little EDC
pouch which stands for everyday carry
now this pouch is actually inspired by a
really low quality mesh pouch that I've
been using for the past couple of years
but the thing that I loved about it was
the size and how slim it was so we took
everything that I hated about the pouch
which was basically everything except
the size and made an entire new one the
number one thing that I sold Condor blue
when we were working on this is I want a
super high quality zipper I want it to
be massive like if you think that the
zipper is too big then that's perfect
then you've definitely hit the mark
here's the zippers so these have the
aluminum tags right here with my little
logo on them and these match the actual
cable ends themselves so it's definitely
an entire comprehensive look so we've
got the super industrial zipper the
other pouch only had one zipper this has
two which allows you to just kind of
open a little side or or open it all the
way to be able to see what's inside and
it'll give you access to put the zipper
wherever you want it the mesh is also a
little bit higher of a quality it's more
sturdy and it has more of a plasticky
feel instead of like the mesh feel you
can also see what's inside way easier
than those other types of mesh bags we
also added this little spine here to
give it a little more structure it's got
our logos both on it right there I'm
going to show you everything that I
carry and this is everything that I take
with me when I travel like this little
bag here stays packed always even if I
just go on a simple day trip this comes
with me one of the best parts about this
pouch is we also added an apple pencil
Loop so if you want to bring a pencil
with you whether it's an apple pencil or
an analog pen that'll also fit here as
well it is on both sides so you can
carry two pencils and I always carry
with me this 35 watt double dual charger
by Apple I like this because it does
have the two USBC slots so I can charge
two things at once this is of course
just a basic apple one this is a Sony
USBC card reader this will oh my gosh is
there a card in there oh that's a treat
this will hold CF Express a cards and
also regular SD cards I mostly use this
for CF Express a cards since the MacBook
does have an SD card slot on it now
would have been so nice to have that
many many years ago but it's okay it's
okay who's complaining not me I always
carry with me my aura ring charger and
since I got my gold ring I now carry
with me my extra ring because there have
been times when I've been traveling and
I actually left my ring at home because
I left it on the charger I like to
charge it before I travel but sometimes
I forget it so I now always make sure I
have my alternate ring packed and ready
to go this is the magsafe duo charger so
you can charge your Apple watch or your
new airpods Pro 2 and this side will
charge your iPhone or anything else
that's she Wireless compatible this
cable super random this cable is
actually what is used to charge my
lightsabers and I used to travel a lot
when I would do lightsaber training I
would always bring a lightsaber with me
and it would be tragic when I wasn't
able to charge it this always stays in
there a USBC 2A dongle honestly never
really need this there was one time last
year when I needed this desperately when
I was in Mexico and I was in the middle
of nowhere no one had a dongle no stores
to even get a dongle so this now always
stays in the bag now let's move on to
the cables shall we okay I'm pretty much
a USBC girl I really just bring this USB
a brick just in case of emergencies we
never know I have two lightning to USBC
cables I always like to have one of
those that plug into the magsafe duo
charger and then I do sometimes travel
with an extra phone so I like to be able
to plug that in to the duo and charge my
other iPhone while the other one is
charging on the magsafe duo charger
sometimes I also do need it to transfer
data so it's just nice to have two of
those those now since this is more of my
travel bag I like to bring some smaller
cables so this is the USBC to USBC we've
got two of those actually and then I
have a thunderbolt cable here which I
always use with some of my various solid
state drives I know I did say it was a
USBC girl but it looks like since I got
these new cables I did decide to throw
in one of these USB C2 usb-a so honestly
it is good to have this because you
honestly really just never know what
you're going to need I will sometimes
travel with a power strip that does have
USB ports on it and those normally are
usb-a which sucks but it is what it is
my micro is missing I also usually have
a micro in here but I think I think it
might be charging something right now
please hold where did you go little
micro here it is I was charging my
microphone with it but this is the USB
micro it's really this ends up being
what I need this for USB micro was such
an interesting cable because obviously
it is something that is on its way out
but there's so many things that still
charge with USB micro headphones all of
the microphones that I use they charge
with USB micro I'm sure one day it will
be updated but for the time being that's
what I'm using so I do have a whole
bunch of accessories little tiny action
cameras all sorts of things that still
use it and of course I wanted it to be a
nice comprehensive collection so I do
feel like there may be people that are
in the market for it I mean if I am then
I can't be alone so this is everything
that is in my carry bag now the reason
that I love this bag so much is because
it is so slim and also this zipper is
super industrial so you are able to cram
a lot of stuff in here now you may be
like we'll just see why didn't you just
make the bag bigger if you wanted to
carry more stuff that's where I had to
draw the line that's why I like the size
of that old crappy cheap bag so much is
because it can find me to this size only
and this fits perfectly into my backpack
so I didn't want to stray from that and
I also didn't want to give myself any
more space to hoard so this is it if it
doesn't fit in here then
well I just need to put it somewhere
else but this is everything that I would
need when I'm on the go I love having
every single cable now matching and
beautiful I just love the way that these
look and it's super exciting because
Condor blue does have a lifetime
warranty on all of their cables so that
is definitely something I feel like will
put your mind to ease if I was on the
market for cables you better believe
that's something I would want so let's
load this back up put in all my items
I mean like really a lightsaber charging
cable
dude you just never know
and there it is all packed up ready to
go
it's just so great they really took my
vision and made it perfect like this is
exactly what I've always wanted and now
it's here and it's something that we
made together so thank you Condor blue
for making my dreams come true this is
so exciting
foreign
[Music]